[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES HANSEN: Well,
thank you very much.
And I love the
informality of the event.
I was a university
professor for 32 years.
I taught classes sometimes
during the noon hour.
And they weren't supposed
to bring food or drink in,
but they, of course,
did it anyway.
So I'm used to just
about anything happening
in an audience.
And so it'll be very relaxed.
And I'm very happy to be
here at Google to meet you,
to see your facility.
Just as an aside before I
get started, Mark and Rick
Armstrong, Neil
Armstrong's two sons,
I've gotten to know quite well.
And one thing that
Rick told me was
that their nickname for
their dad in later years
was Mr. Google, because
Neil had this sort
of all embracing knowledge
about so many different fields.
And so I guess maybe
they were teasing him
a bit that whenever something
would be brought up,
he felt he would contribute
some additional knowledge
on the subject.
So he was-- I
suppose there's lots
of Mr Googles in the world, but
Neil Armstrong was one of them.
Biography, I'm
trained as a historian
of science and technology.
And I didn't really
write my first biography
until this book, which I started
writing in the early 2000s.
And it was originally
published in 2005.
Biography is not easy to write.
I suppose that's why I like
trying to do it so much.
Writing biography is
always challenging.
Just how difficult it
is to write a biography
can be reckoned by
anybody who sits down
and considers just
how many people,
how few people really know
the truth, the real truth,
about the secrets
that you hold closest
to your heart and
deepest in your minds.
So I think there's always
something almost inherently
unfathomable about
us as individuals.
And a biographer
does his or her best
to try to find
out those secrets.
But there's always some
part of the person, I think,
that we just can't achieve
a complete understanding.
And maybe that's for the best.
Biography is even
more challenging
when it's not just biography,
but it's also iconography,
when it's a study
of an iconic person
onto whom various levels of
myth and symbol and poetry
and fiction have been projected
by society and culture.
And I think in the
case of Armstrong
that certainly is part of it.
So it's a biography
and an iconography.
And for that reason, I think it
makes it especially fascinating
to study.
I'll tell you a story that I
think is very illuminating.
Neil grew up in a series
of small towns in Ohio.
He was born in 1930.
And his father was--
both his father and
mother grew up on a farm.
And they had eighth
grade educations.
But the father had
studied accounting.
And he got a job in the early
'30s during the Depression
as an auditor for
the state of Ohio.
And as a result
of this, he would
be assigned a certain county
to go in and do the books
and do an audit for that county.
And he was an expert.
Having grown up on a
farm, he was an expert
on accounting as it related to
farm land and farm businesses.
And so Ohio was
mostly farm counties,
with the exception
of the major towns.
And so the family went to
places where they were really
out in the countryside.
And so Neil, by the time he
was-- again, born in 1930--
by the time he was
9 or 10, he'd lived
in six or seven different
towns, small towns in Ohio.
Now, they were all
the county seats,
usually, or near
but they were still rural areas.
And when dad was
done with the job--
it took about a year.
And then they would move on,
and sometimes across the state.
And so the family
would get up and move.
And so Neil was on the
move with his family
as a boy in various towns.
Now, he ends up in a
town called Wapakoneta,
which is in northwestern
Ohio, very agricultural.
It's about 50 miles
north of Dayton
if you need your
geographical situation.
So he arrives in Wapakoneta just
in time to begin high school.
Ninth grade, which
was high school
for the kids in Wapakoneta.
And it was a town back
then around the late 1930s,
1940 that probably had
about 20,000 people.
But it was the county
seat of Auglaize County.
Well, in Wapakoneta where
Neil starts high school,
there is a man in
Wapakoneta named Jacob Zint.
Jacob was an engineer.
He worked at Westinghouse up the
road from Wapakoneta in a town
called Lima, Ohio.
And he was a bachelor.
He was kind of the
town's Mr. Wizard.
You're all too young to
remember the Mr. Wizard show.
But Mr. Wizard just could
explain all things science
and invented things.
And that was true of Jake Zint.
And you're seeing
Jacob Zint's house,
which was about a
block and a half
away from the Armstrong
home in Wapakoneta.
And one thing that
Mr. Zint had done.
I think I can do my laser.
Up here, where the arrow
is pointing, he had--
the top floor up in
the attic of his house,
he had built an
astronomical observatory
that included a telescope.
And in early 1969 when
NASA announced the crew
for Apollo 11; Neil Armstrong,
Buzz Aldrin, Mike Collins--
this was still before
Apollo 9 and Apollo 10
had completed their mission.
But if they were going to
be completed successfully
as they were, then Apollo 11
would be the first landing
attempt.
So the announcement
of this first crew,
and especially after 9 and
after 10 were completed,
and it was clear that 11 was
going to attempt the landing,
all of a sudden there was a lot
of attention on the Apollo 11
crew, who these guys were.
The media wanted to
know more about--
they wanted to write
feature stories
about these first
men that were going
to be landing on the moon.
And Neil as the
commander-- and once
it was clear that the commander
was going to be stepping out
first to become the first
man on another planet,
there was a lot of attention.
I mean, reporters from
all around the world
came to this little Ohio
town to learn what they
could about Neil Armstrong.
They talked to
anybody and everybody
that had stories about
Armstrong growing up.
Of course, he'd only been
there since his freshman year.
But he spent his whole
high school there.
And he'd played in the
band and different things.
And so they come to Wapakoneta.
And one person that talked
to the reporters a lot
was Jacob Zint.
Jacob Zint told them this story.
He told them that when--
Neil was very active
in the Boy Scouts.
He becomes an Eagle Scout,
as you can see Neil here
in his scout uniform.
He always looked young, a very
young, handsome little boy.
He looked always
younger than he was.
In fact, he skipped a grade.
In one of the towns that he went
to, when they sort of tested
him, they realized his
reading abilities were really
a grade higher than his age.
So I think he skipped
the second grade.
He went from first to third.
So he was always
younger than his peers.
But Zint told the reporters
the story that Neil's Boy Scout
troop came to the Zint home,
was invited by Zint to the home.
And Zint took them up
to the observatory.
And he told them about
how he built the telescope
and how a telescope operates.
And then he let every boy come
and look through the telescope.
And when the program
was over, there
was this little blond boy that
was sort of hanging around.
And he was kind of shy.
And Mr. Zint said he came--
this young boy came
up to him and asked
if he could come back.
And of course, this
was Neil Armstrong.
And according to Mr. Zint, Neil
came back many, many times.
He looked through the telescope.
They had long conversations
about how the moon was formed
and the universe.
I mean, it was just
broad discussions.
And Mr. Zint said even in a
later story that was reported--
and these stories were
reported by the AP Press
and went national and
I think international.
Zint said that on the eve
of the Apollo 11 launch,
that Neil had gotten a
message to him saying that he
was going to check out--
when he got to the
moon, he was going
to test some of the theories
that they had discussed years
before.
Well, the Zint story,
here you see a selection
of children's books about
Neil that have been published.
And all of these
had been published
by the time I started
my research on Neil
in the early 2000s.
There are now a few more
that have been done.
But the Jacob Zint story
was in all of these books,
because it really sort of--
it makes so much sense that the
person who becomes an astronaut
and becomes the
first man on the moon
would have this
kind of background
and this sort of interest
in astronomy and cosmology
and whatever.
Back to this slide.
So when I'm
interviewing Neil, and I
had a total of 55 hours
of tape recorded interview
with him, which was
exceptional, because Neil
didn't give many interviews.
And if you were lucky enough
to get an interview with him,
you might have 30 minutes.
And you didn't-- you needed to
go right to the moon landing,
right?
I mean, you couldn't waste time
with a lot of other discussion.
But I had 55 hours with
him over several months.
And I didn't talk to
him about the moon
probably until my
30th hour or more.
But so I was going through
sort of sequentially,
talking first about his family
background, his boyhood.
And given the prominence
of the Jacob Zint story,
I thought I wanted to
hear more about this.
It was fascinating.
It seemed to define so
much about his life,
the arc of his life story.
So I said, tell me more about
your time with Jacob Zint.
And Neil looked
down at the ground.
We were sitting in his study.
And he looked back up.
And he said to
me, it's not true.
I said, it's not true.
What's not true?
He said, well, it is true that
we were invited to his home.
He took us up to
the observatory.
He told us-- he lectured
to us about the telescope.
He would not let any of us
look through the telescope.
And when the evening ended,
I never saw Mr. Zint again.
He wouldn't have
known me passing
by the street on my bicycle.
He wouldn't have
known who I was.
And I said to him, really?
I said-- and at that point,
I pull out of my folders--
I had a bunch of
clippings, not only
these stories that
we're published
all over the place about Zint
and his relationship with Neil
Armstrong.
But about a month after Apollo
11 came back from the moon,
there was a big
parade in Wapakoneta.
The Purdue Marching Band.
Neil had gone to Purdue and
played in the marching band.
The Purdue Marching Band and
the Golden Girls from Purdue
were in the parade.
Bob Hope, the entertainer
who's from Ohio, he was there.
The governor of Ohio,
Jim Rhodes, was there.
Neil and his family were
riding in open convertibles.
And guess who else was riding
in an open convertible.
Jacob Zint had his
own open convertible,
because he had
become a local hero
for this role he played in
helping the formation of Neil
Armstrong's interest in space.
So I said, Neil, he's
got his own convertible.
I said, didn't you correct this?
And Neil said, ah, I--
literally he said this, I didn't
want to rain on his parade.
So he never-- and in fact, as
I look back on it in the months
later and certainly now, if I
had not asked him specifically
about Jacob Zint, Neil would
never have told me about it.
He only answered the
questions that I asked him.
So if I had not asked
him about Jacob Zint,
we wouldn't have
gotten that corrected.
The story would
have perpetuated.
Another couple of twists,
sort of ending footnotes
to this, the telescope
and kind of the structure
that Mr. Zint had built around
it for his observatory was
eventually, I think,
sold by the Zint family
to the Auglaize County Museum.
And it in fact became
the centerpiece
of the whole museum
because of its role
in the formation of
young Neil Armstrong.
I'm giving a talk after the book
comes out in Dayton, just down
the road.
And my wife is sitting
in the back of the room.
It's about this size of a crowd.
A little bit larger, maybe.
And at the end I'm signing some
books and talking to people.
And I see my wife is talking
to somebody in the back.
And when the room
sort of clears,
she comes up front with a man.
And she says, this gentleman
wants to talk to you.
It was the nephew of Jacob Zint.
The family was quite
disturbed by what
they had read in my
book about Jacob Zint,
because they believed Uncle Jake
had really done these things.
And they questioned
whether I was really--
whether I was right
about this or not.
And all I could tell them
was I have recordings where
I talk about this with Neil.
Neil was very plain about it.
Write him if you choose.
And I think they later did.
But this was a very
significant story for me.
Actually, in the new
edition of the book,
we wanted to shorten the
book in some respects.
And my editor wanted to cut
the Jacob Zint story out
of the book.
And I said, no, no,
no, you can't do that.
It's such an important story.
Because what it
informed me about was
I couldn't trust anything
that was out there.
I was going to have to
question and interrogate
the evidence so carefully,
because if Zint told a story,
who knows?
The moon landing was such
a big thing, especially
in Ohio and in the
town of Wapakoneta.
People wanted to be
part of the story.
So I did-- as a result of my
awareness of this possibility,
I did test a lot of
the oral history,
a lot of the
testimony, and found
that there were lots of
exaggerations and fabrications.
And I didn't want
to debunk them just
for the purposes of
getting the facts straight.
I wanted to understand
why people were doing it.
What it tells us not
about Neil so much,
but about us, about
society and culture.
And as I did find out, I
was writing an iconography,
because he became
such a global icon.
And so much was
projected onto him.
This is the trajectory that you
get in a very simplified form
if you accept the Jacob Zint
story, that Neil as a boy
became very interested
in astronomy.
He was a dreamer.
Eyes to the heavens,
looking through telescopes.
Very interested in the moon.
Read a lot of science fiction.
And thus it makes
total sense that this
is the guy that would from that
boy would become the astronaut,
would make the moon landing.
It's so logical, but
completely false.
It's a false narrative.
As much as it makes
sense, it doesn't.
It's not true.
And so my job as the
biographer was not
only to make that
clear, but to show
the real, the reality of it.
And the reality of it was
Neil was all about airplanes.
As a boy, a little boy,
he saved every penny.
He begged his mother
every time they
went to the hardware store.
He wanted stuff to
build model airplanes.
I show this slide.
You see his brother and
sister over in the right side.
And he was a proto-engineer.
And one example from his early--
from his childhood.
By the time he was maybe--
this was when he was 10 or 11.
He would have models
that he wasn't really
all that happy with.
He would decide, well, let's
do something special with them.
So he would take his
brother and sister
to the upstairs window
of one of the bedrooms.
And he would show them how
he wanted them to throw
the models out of the window.
And then after he'd
show them, there
would be maybe a dozen of
them on the bed for them to--
sort of the staging area.
He would run down.
And there was one of
these old driveways
that had concrete strips
with grass in between.
And he had a bunch
of popsicle sticks.
And as the airplanes would
be shot out of the window
and would land, he would
mark where they'd landed
with his popsicle sticks.
And he would write with the
pencil which airplane it was.
And he had a notebook.
And he'd write down the
results of the flight tests,
gather them up,
bring them back up,
have them shot out
the window again.
Take down the notes.
He was doing flight research.
He becomes a test pilot.
He's a proto-engineer as a boy.
He had his pilot's license
before his driver's license.
He started going out to
this little grass airfield
on the edge of Wapakoneta when
he was maybe 13, 14 years old.
He'd help the mechanics.
He'd do whatever they
would let him to do just
to be around the airplanes.
And then he saved up
money for flying lessons.
And he got his license on his
birthday, his 16th birthday.
He hadn't even been
interested in driving.
So that's the story that
really needed to be told.
He enters Purdue in 1947 to
become an aircraft designer.
That's what he wants to be.
He wants to design airplanes.
17 years old.
He goes there on a
Navy scholarship.
And after two years
of his education,
the Korean War breaks out.
And he is called to Pensacola
to do naval aviator training.
And this is my very favorite
picture of Armstrong.
It's right after
his first carrier
landing in the Gulf of
Mexico, March of 1950.
He was 19.
He looks like he's maybe 12.
And just by far my
favorite picture.
I got all of his Navy records.
It was really interesting
to follow all of the reports
by the pilots who
were instructing him
and what they were saying about
his flying, which wasn't always
perfect.
It wasn't perfect at all.
So he goes from there.
He gets assigned eventually to a
fighter squadron that is really
one of the first all jet fighter
plane squadrons in the US Navy.
He's flying the Panther jet.
He's part of VF-51
and goes to Korea.
He flies 78 combat
missions over North Korea.
Very exciting.
Very formative part of his life.
He would go to reunions
of the fighter squadron
almost every time they had them.
Whereas astronaut
reunions, he was very
selective about going to those.
Then when he comes back, he
finishes his degree at Purdue.
He's still interested
in aircraft design,
but he loves the flying.
And so he realizes
that there is this job.
There is this kind of engineer.
It's the engineering
research pilot, the guys
with the real right stuff.
Engineers in the airplanes.
So he gets a job with what
was then the National Advisory
Committee for Aeronautics, or
NACA, which was the agency that
preceded NASA, and which really
provided the nucleus for NASA
when NASA was established
in 1958 following Sputnik.
So he gets a job.
He first gets assigned
to Cleveland, actually.
But Scotty Crossfield, who was
the first pilot to fly Mach 2,
Crossfield left the
NACA in '56 in order
to become the chief test pilot
for North American Aviation,
which was building the X-15.
So Crossfield
moved over and left
a spot open at Edwards, on
the civilian side of Edwards.
Neil took that.
So that's how he
gets to Edwards.
He stays there.
He flies 50 different
types of airplanes.
Lots and lots of times in jets.
And very significantly for
his astronaut selection,
he's the only one
of the astronauts
in either of the first or second
class of astronauts that had
any experience flying a rocket.
And that's the X-15.
Of course, the very first scene
of the movie is an X-15 flight.
So that's Neil.
And he then chooses--
he entered astronaut
selection at that point.
So this is the real trajectory.
Not the trajectory that we
build from Jacob Zint's story,
but the boy that has this
passion for airplanes, that
wants to be an aircraft
designer, that's
a proto-engineer doing flight
research as a 10-year-old out
of his bedroom window, goes to
Purdue, becomes a test pilot.
And it's really a trajectory
that's not completely
a trajectory of his
own, because if you're
looking at what's happening
to the history of flight,
over the course of
the '40s and '50s,
you're having the move
from subsonic to transonic
to supersonic to
hypersonic flight.
That's happening.
And since Neil's
in a position where
he's employed to be testing
these vehicles as they're
coming online to be tested,
Neil goes with that trajectory.
The technology is
taking him there.
It's not like he ever intended
to be flying into space.
He never thought
about that as a boy.
But that's where the
technology, that's where
the progress was taking flight.
And he went with it, and
was in a great position
in terms of timing, in terms
of his age and his experience.
He was perfectly situated
to take advantage of it
if he chose to go that route.
This is a very, I think,
illuminating quotation
from Neil, something
that he said to me
in one of my interviews.
Neil, I think it's right
to call him an explorer,
but I think to really
understand him,
this quotation gets much
closer to the truth.
"What I attended to was
the progressive development
of flight machinery.
My exploration came totally
as a byproduct of that.
I flew to the Moon not
so much to go there,
but as part of developing
the system that
would allow it to happen."
And I think that's a really
critical understanding of how
he saw himself and what
he was actually doing.
So that's myth one.
Neil as a young stargazer,
the Jacob Zint story.
That's a myth, I think, really,
biographical you have to bust,
or you're really never going
to fathom who the guy was.
Actually, I could give
you-- if you invite me
back about 10 times, I could
go through all the myths
that there are about Armstrong.
I'm only going to concentrate
on two of them really today.
But there are an incredible
number of myths about him
if you really want
to understand him.
The book tries to lay them out.
Myth two.
I guess there are three of
them I'm going to talk about.
I kind of already
hinted at this.
"The Right Stuff."
I loved the book.
Tom Wolfe's book from 1979.
Whenever I taught my graduate
seminar in aerospace history
at Auburn, I always had
the students read it.
It's a fabulous read.
It's great for conversation.
And what is the right stuff?
I looked through the book again.
I looked through my notes
on when I taught the book.
And this is the
closest thing I could
get to a singular definition.
"The ability of a pilot to
go up in a hurtling piece
of machinery and put
his hide on the line
and then have the moxie, the
reflexes, the experience,
the coolness to pull it
back at the last yawning
moment, and then go up
again, even if the series
should prove infinite."
That's the closest thing to the
right stuff, based on Wolfe's
book, that I could get.
Of course, the image
of the right stuff
is you've got these proud,
unwilling to admit weakness,
not given to small
talk or introspection,
very courageous, very
charismatic, somewhat arrogant,
occasionally kind of
coarse, very competitive.
That's the image
of the right stuff
that Wolfe is really
telling us about.
And of course, in the book
and in the movie from 1984
that resulted from
the book, who's
the one with the
real right stuff?
Is it an astronaut?
No, it's Chuck Yeager.
And that's a myth as
far as I'm concerned.
I think as far as a lot
of historians of flight
are concerned.
Neil, I think, and
pilots like Neil,
had what I call the real
right stuff, that were not
trying to break records.
They were trying to learn.
They were trying
to build knowledge.
They were engineers
in the cockpit trying
to learn about the machine, the
environment the machine was in,
the relationship of the
pilot to the machine.
Data.
You need to get data
from your flights.
You'll never hear Chuck Yeager
in his whole life talking
about knowledge or data.
It's about other things.
The real right
stuff, in my view,
is what has really contributed
to the progress of flight.
I gave talks at what was
then NASA Dryden-- it's now
NASA Armstrong-- where
I've gone on at length
about the real right stuff.
And my book talks
about it as well.
And I'll tell you a little
story which was crucial to,
I think, my getting
Armstrong to agree
to letting me do the book.
You're seeing a picture
of an NACA/NASA test pilot
by the name of Jack
Reeder, who was
a test pilot from 1943 to 1982.
Not a famous name that
you would recognize,
but I got to know Jack
pretty well, quite
well, because my first
job out of grad school
was to write a book about NASA
Langley, the oldest of the NASA
facilities, because it was
the first NACA facility.
Reeder I got to know quite
well, and learned a lot
about the real right
stuff from him.
He actually had been an
engineer from Michigan Tech who
wasn't originally a pilot.
He was an engineer in the full
scale wind tunnel at Langley.
But during the war, Second
World War, they needed more--
I mean, pilots were going out
to the Pacific and to Europe
to fight.
And NACA was short on pilots.
So they took some
of their engineers
who were willing to do it.
And they sent them through.
Jack went down to Pensacola
and went through naval aviation
training, and then came
back to be a test pilot,
and became a superb test pilot.
I'm going to skip over
this one, because I
am kind of talking about this.
I mean, there is this cult of
the astronaut that is still
kind of tied to the
real right stuff
that I think is important
to demystify, demythologize.
I think there's a lot about
our social and cultural
apprehension of the astronaut,
which is not the best
understanding, I think, of
what the astronauts truly
contributed.
I guess I got rid of one, but
I need to go back to this then.
But here's the key that I wanted
to mention with Jack Reeder.
It took me about
two years to get
Neil to agree to do the
book, to give me the access.
And the critical moment
came when I went to his home
in suburban Cincinnati
and sat with him
for the afternoon,
talked to him,
a brief, flowing conversation.
It wasn't an interview.
It wasn't recorded.
And his wife, Carol,
his second wife,
came in and out of the
room from time to time.
And at one point I
mentioned to him something
about Jack Reeder.
And I wasn't fishing
for anything.
I had no reason to--
I had no reason to
think he actually
even knew who Jack Reeder was.
The minute I
mentioned Jack Reeder,
Neil turns to his
wife, Carol, and says,
Jack Reeder was the best
test pilot I ever knew.
And then he turns back
to me and he says,
and Chuck Yeager was the worst.
That's the only
time I ever heard
Neil say anything
bad about anybody,
which meant he really had some
intense feelings about Chuck
Yeager.
Read Yeager's autobiography
from years ago.
And you'll see what Yeager
has to say about Neil.
It's worse than what Neil
has to say about Yeager.
They were not on
the same wavelength.
But you might remember
that phrase the most.
But what you really-- what
I really wanted to emphasize
was the first part
of what Niel said.
Jack Reeder was the best
test pilot I ever knew.
Because Jack was an engineer.
He was an engineering research
pilot, about knowledge,
about data, the engineer in the
cockpit, the real right stuff.
And I just--
I was pretty happy that he
knew who Jack Reeder was.
And leaving the home that
day, I kind of thought, gosh,
what are the odds that I'm
going to mention to Neil someone
who he thinks is the best
test pilot he ever knew?
It took another year after that
to get the final green light
from him.
But I think Neil appreciated
the fact that I understood.
I mean, if I had
said to him that day,
boy, I really love Chuck Yeager.
What do you think about Yeager?
I probably wouldn't
have gotten the book.
Really, I don't think I
would have gotten the book.
But instead, I knew why Chuck--
I not only knew who Jack Reeder
was and was a friend of Jack
Reeder's.
I knew why he was
important, and why
his flying was the kind
of flying that really
meant a lot to progress.
I think I might have cinched
the book deal with Neil
right then and there.
Do I have time for
one more story?
Do I?
I don't know when you guys
have to be back to work.
This is work.
This should be
considered work, right?
This is the last myth that
I'm going to talk about.
And it's also about
his childhood.
And I'm a strong believer
as a human being, let alone
a biographer, that the child
is the father to the man.
If you don't understand the
development of the child--
in this case, Neil growing
up, personality development,
understanding his parents, his
family situation, his siblings,
his community--
then you really can't
understand what he becomes
and who he becomes.
And of course,
that's the problem
when you have a movie like
"First Man" where you pick up
the story in 1961
when he's a test pilot
and you don't have any of
the background material.
You really kind of--
from my point of
view as a biographer,
it's really kind of
hard to really know
who this guy was if
you don't know really
the formation of who he was.
This is Neil's mother, Viola.
She was a really important
person from my book.
Unfortunately, she
died in the early '90s.
So I didn't get
to interview her.
But I did interview, besides
Neil, his two siblings,
his sister June and
his brother Dean.
And his sister
June was absolutely
crucial to what I
could then-- what
I would learn about Neil and
the family and the mother.
And June actually
made available to me--
after the Apollo 11 mission
and Neil becoming this world
famous person,
Viola wrote a series
of really kind of
family memoirs.
Most of them focusing
on Neil, but also
talking about her upbringing
and the deep family background,
but a lot about Neil.
So Viola was a really
important character.
The relationship between
Neil and his mother
is especially
important, I think,
to understand who Neil became.
So here's the story.
In February 1970 a few
months after Apollo 11,
there's a story published in
"Guideposts" magazine, which
is a Christian magazine.
Viola Armstrong was a very
devout evangelical Christian.
And the story was Neil
Armstrong's boyhood crisis.
And the story that Viola
told that got published
in this magazine was
that Neil, just soon
after he started flying
out of a grass airfield--
actually, he was with
his father, his brother,
and a friend coming back.
His father was driving the car.
They were coming
back from a Boy Scout
Jamboree in northeastern--
northwestern Ohio.
And they were
coming back to town.
And as they got to
the outskirts of town,
they saw one of the
Aeronca airplanes
that the student pilots were in.
And it was coming down.
And it hit the telephone
wires and crashed.
And Mr. Armstrong drove
as close to the airfield
as he could get.
And they all rushed
out of the car.
And Neil got there first.
And it was an older
boy, but someone Neil
knew that was also
taking flying lessons.
And according to the
story that was published,
the boy dies in Neil's arms.
And as Viola told
the story, the crisis
then became Neil was
very disturbed by this,
and for the next several days
didn't come out of his room.
And Viola said he was reading
his Bible and praying to Jesus.
He wasn't sure he
should ever fly again.
And then one day he
came out of his room.
I mean, she was
bringing him his food.
He was crying and depressed.
And one day he came
out of the room,
and he told her-- went
right to her and said,
god has told me that
I need to keep flying.
I should keep flying.
And so I'm going to keep flying.
And so that was the crisis, that
Neil could have stopped flying.
Well, I wanted to hear
more about that story.
I did have the clippings from
the local paper about the crash
and what was said at
the time and so forth.
And Neil was involved.
There's no question
that the crash happened.
Neil and the parents, his dad,
and his brother were there.
I wanted to hear more about it.
And I had this story
from the "Guideposts."
And I think I actually talked
to his sister about this first
before I talked
to Neil about it.
So I asked June about it.
And she said, yeah, we
remember that story very well.
It's a bunch of baloney.
We remember the crash.
Neil had no crisis.
He never questioned whether
he was going to fly again.
I don't remember him being
up in his room like this.
You just have to understand mom.
Mom had this really
fervent religious belief.
She talked about
religion with us a lot.
She wanted us to talk about
different Bible passages
at dinner time.
And Neil never bought into that.
Neil never really didn't
embrace her beliefs.
And in fact, what
June told me was
Neil really is not--
he believes in god,
but he doesn't believe in
any particular doctrine.
So I'm not even sure
he's really a Christian.
And I said to her,
I said, well, when
your mother talked about
religion, what did Neil do?
She said, well, he would listen.
He never-- he was not
the argumentative type.
In fact, I've never seen him
in an argument his whole life.
What he would do is he
would listen politely,
not say anything,
then walk away.
He didn't want to argue.
Whatever his beliefs were,
he kept them to himself.
So when I interviewed him,
I asked him the questions.
And the story was--
I mean, he was a little less
wordy about what was going on.
But it's clear from what
he said that his mother--
again, it was like mom just--
there were things mom wanted
to believe that we just
let her keep believing.
But I did-- when I
interviewed other people--
and this includes astronauts
and flight controllers and other
people who worked with him--
I always asked, did you ever
seen Neil in an argument?
No, he didn't argue.
It didn't mean he
agreed with us.
But he had other ways of
getting what he wanted done.
He didn't argue.
And I think that it was a
conflict avoidance strategy
that he had learned pretty
young as a boy in relationship
to his mother.
So another myth
that's out there has
to do with his
religious beliefs.
And again, as a
biographer, I'm not
trying to prove any point one
way or another about religion.
I'm just trying to tell a story
and be as faithful and accurate
about Armstrong as possible.
There is a story that
circulates even today.
Neil visited Jerusalem at
some point later in life.
And the story goes that when
he was on the stairs climbing
to the Temple Mount in
Jerusalem, that he professed
his Christian religious beliefs.
In fact, this is a story from
"Tablet" magazine that comes--
and it's a story that
actually appeared earlier
in other places,
but it was repeated.
This was actually two days after
Neil died in August of 2012.
And the story goes--
it says, when American
astronaut Neil Armstrong,
a devout Christian, visited
Israel after his trip
to the moon, he was taken
on a tour of the Old City.
When they got to the
stairs of the steps
leading to the Temple
Mount, Armstrong
asked the guy who was escorting
them whether Jesus had
stopped anywhere around there.
And the man said, these are the
steps that lead to the temple.
So he must have walked
here many times.
And Neil said, so Jesus
stepped right here.
That's right.
Well, I have to
tell you, I am more
excited stepping on
these stones than I
was stepping on the moon.
I had already talked to
Neil about this story
because it appeared earlier.
And I talked to Carol, his wife,
who was with him in Jerusalem
for this visit.
It's a totally fabricated story.
I mean, not that
he wasn't there,
but it's not-- he never said it.
There are people that want
to believe this about him.
It's just not-- it's
simply not true.
This is the truth.
I mean, actually,
there were stories
about Neil's religious beliefs
that came up in the press
prior to Apollo 11.
There was a woman who was
very famous American atheist,
Madalyn Murray O'Hair.
Some people called her--
I mean, the press dubbed her
the most hated woman in America,
because she was
suing the government
over reading from the book
of Genesis on Apollo 8.
And she picked up something in
a German magazine, an interview
with Neil, and it
suggested to her
that Neil was an atheist,
which he was not.
He was a deist.
But that became enough news
that when Neil and the crew
were on "Face the Nation" on CBS
in the weeks after Apollo 11,
Walter Cronkite asked Neil,
when you were on the moon,
did you feel closer to god?
That's a question that came
up to a lot of the astronauts.
Well, what did Neil answer?
Walter, sometimes a man
just wants a good cigar.
Total non-sequitur.
And watching Cronkite's
facial expression
is priceless, because he's
not sure he's heard it right.
But he does realize,
well, clearly I'm
not supposed to
pursue that topic.
And he did not.
There's Madalyn Murray
O'Hair and her claim
that he was an atheist,
which is not true either.
As I said, he was a deist.
Now, here's a story that
persists to this day.
If you get on your
computer and Google--
Google, yeah.
I don't think I've ever
had such fun saying that.
Google Neil
Armstrong plus Islam.
You will get hundreds
of thousands of hits.
The story circulated not
long after Apollo 11,
that while on the lunar surface,
Neil heard this strange singing
or whatever.
He didn't know what it was.
He heard it again once
he was back on Earth.
He learned that it was
the Muslim call to prayer.
And he converts to Islam.
In fact, as the story went, he
moved to Lebanon, which he did.
Lebanon, Ohio, which is a
little town north of Cincinnati.
He lived on a farm there.
But this is a story that would
not go away, and to the point
where in the mid '80s Neil
was getting invitations
to go speak at mosques and
talk about his conversion.
And he goes to the State
Department and says,
can you help with this?
I'm getting all these requests.
And so they helped.
They put out a
circular to send around
embassies in Islamic countries.
And Neil also did
a teleconference
with journalists in
Cairo, Egypt and answered
all their questions,
and made it clear.
No, he wasn't.
Go back here again.
And in fact, one story Neil told
me was when he was at Purdue,
he was back at his
fraternity house.
And there was a little
reception for him.
And a young student came up
to him who was from Turkey.
And the student said,
he got him at a time
when he was just by himself.
And he said, could you tell me
about your conversion to Islam?
And Neil tried to tell
him, it's not true.
I've had to explain
this many times.
And the young man listened.
And he said then to
Neil, well, my dad
told me that you were going
to have to lie about it,
because, I mean, the story, the
conspiracy is that he converts.
And the reason
he's such a recluse
is the United States government
doesn't want this story known.
And so they've sort of
hidden him away from people.
So they don't really
discover the truth
about his religious beliefs.
And again, I write
about this in the book.
I have lectured about it.
But the number of hits on
Google just keep going up.
So it's still out
there as if it's true.
Like I said, he was a deist.
And if you need a
lot of famous deists,
deism sort of grows out of the
18th century enlightenment.
And I know he's a deist, because
I talked to him about it.
And on one of the--
when he was a test
pilot at Edwards,
he got involved with
a Boy Scout troop.
And he had to fill
out an application.
This troop was run
through this local church.
He filled out the application.
And on religious
affiliation, he wrote deist.
The minister didn't
know what that was.
So he called a fellow
test pilot at Edwards
that the minister knew and
was one of their parishioners.
And he said, this
Neil Armstrong sounds
like a great-- seems like a
great guy, but what's deist?
And his friend, Stan Butchart
said to the minister, well,
I don't really know
what that is either,
but he's a really great man.
And I wouldn't worry about it.
So anyway.
Well, I'm going to stop there.
As I said, I've got lots
and lots of myths to cover.
I will just conclude
that the myth that he did
become a recluse
is not really true.
He did a lot of things.
And I think more and more in
the later decades of his life,
he had to be pretty
choosy about what he did.
And he didn't grant
interviews unless he thought
it was a newsworthy item
that he had some expertise
to comment on.
But he wasn't
interested in people
doing feature stories on him.
So he turned down lots and
lots of interview requests.
And I think the idea that he
became a recluse was really
created by media that had failed
to get him to do an interview.
So it's easier just to say
instead of we were rejected,
he's a recluse.
He wasn't a recluse.
He did tons and tons of stuff.
So anyway, is there time?
Is there time?
SPEAKER: We have a couple
of minutes for questions,
but I'm going to like
hog the mic for a second
and say, well,
thank you very much.
That was amazing and
really informative.
JAMES HANSEN: Thank you.
SPEAKER: And delightful.
I'm going to throw
the mic to Scott next,
but I'm going to ask
a question first.
Did you get an opportunity
to talk to Neil
about the conspiracy
theorists that say
that the moon landing was fake?
Because that's hilarious to me.
And I'm just wondering
what he said about it.
JAMES HANSEN: It's
hilarious on one level.
And it's really depressing
on another level,
because it doesn't go away.
It continues to this day,
maybe even at a greater volume
than ever before.
No, I did talk to him about it.
And I'm doing two books.
Purdue Press, we're doing
two volumes of Neil's papers;
letters to Neil, and
then letters from Neil.
And he received a lot of letters
from the conspiracy theory
people.
And he answered most of those.
I mean, a lot of the answers
back to letters that he got--
I mean, he got so much mail.
He had to have assistants
and secretaries.
And a lot of letters
that went back
were kind of by the
secretaries, not by Neil.
But the conspiracy theorists,
he kind of took personally.
And he had a variety
of answers for them.
I think he grew-- it
was clear in the answers
that he was frustrated.
That he couldn't-- no
matter what he said,
he knew he wasn't going to
convince certain people.
One thing that he
commonly said was, look,
this was the Cold War.
This was a race to the
moon with the Soviets.
If the Soviets had
had any suspicion
that this was not really true--
and there were ways of seeing
what the American space
program was doing and
tracking spacecraft--
the Soviets would
have been all over it.
But no, they weren't.
It wasn't like they embraced
it and were blowing trumpets
about the Apollo moon landing
all through the Soviet society,
but Neil was invited
to the Soviet Union
about a year after
and made a trip.
And he got great--
he was treated with great honor
and given medals and things
like that.
So that was one thing
that he answered
that if there had been.
And then another
thing he would say
is that it would have
been harder to fake it
than to actually do it.
Of course, you have to have
some basic understanding
of physics or Newtonian
physics at least
to really understand that.
A lot of people didn't.
I mean, my mother, again, she
had an eighth grade education,
and she didn't believe it.
But for her, she couldn't--
her brain couldn't grasp
the principles that would be
involved in rocket flights
and different things.
So I will publish
some of the letters
from the conspiracy theorists.
I mean, it really got nasty.
There was this one guy who
made a bunch of videos.
I'm not going to even
mention his name.
He's the guy that Buzz Aldrin
here in Beverly Hills smacked.
But this guy followed
everybody around
and wanted them to
swear on a Bible.
And there's videos you can
watch that are just so terrible.
But this guy rented driveway
space in Neil's neighborhood
to capture video of him and
stalked him from airport
to airport, and went to one of
his corporate board meetings.
And some of this was really
intrusive and disturbing.
And I'm sort of in
the same position
that Neil was in, in the
sense that I don't think
there's anything-- for people
that don't believe it happened,
I don't think there's anything
you can say to them that's
going to change their mind.
So I'm not even sure it's
worth the effort at this point.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So first, thank you
for writing a biography of one
of my favorite humans.
I'm very much looking
forward to reading this.
My question was,
in recent years,
there has been a lot of
very welcome attention
on the role of women in
the early space program.
"Hidden Figures," like Katherine
Johnson, and the Mercury 13,
this group of remarkable
female astronaut candidates
in the '60s, who of course
were not selected for flight.
When you were
interviewing Neil, this
would have been before
a lot of that attention.
I'm not sure if you ever
talked to him about it.
But I was just curious if you
had ever talked to him about it
and if you knew what he
thought about these women who
were making these great
contributions at the time that
were at the time largely unsung.
JAMES HANSEN: Yeah.
I did talk to him about it.
And I don't think that the first
couple of classes of astronauts
were terribly aware
of what was going on,
because the program,
the Lovelace clinic,
it wasn't really an official
NASA program, honestly.
It was something
that NASA knew about,
but there was never
a program that
was started to train or
select women astronauts.
And then they went against it.
It was never-- and they
had this qualification
that you had to be a
military test pilot.
And that disqualified them.
AUDIENCE: Right.
JAMES HANSEN: So I think
Neil thought it was--
in retrospect, it was unfair.
But it was a
reflection of the time.
He was very happy that
NASA has changed its tune
and the women are very involved.
And he has even
suggested that he
thinks when there's
a mission to Mars,
it maybe should be an all female
crew, that physiologically,
there's advantages
that women have.
And so I think,
again, I don't think--
at the time, he was so focused
on what he needed to do.
I don't think he was--
he didn't feel like
it was his place
to take up the cause of women.
He just was needed
to do his job, which
was complicated enough.
And was historically aware,
as Mr. Google would be,
historically aware that there
were certain social constraints
that still had not
been conquered,
and fortunately we've
moved past those
in some significant degree.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
JAMES HANSEN: I will say that
in terms of "Hidden Figures,"
I'm proud to say that my
very first book for NASA
in the early 1980s, which was
the history of Langley, NASA
Langley in the NACA period--
and you can find
this on YouTube--
I interviewed a number of the
women, the computers, the women
computers, including
Katherine Johnson.
And I write about them in
a book published in 1983.
They are hidden figures,
but I recognized
the importance of these women
and interviewed them at length.
And when-- and there are
certain-- as with our movie,
"First Man," there are
certain liberties that
are taken in the storyline.
And I had reporters
from the Hampton area
contact me to point
out what I thought
were some of the inaccuracies
in "Hidden Figures."
I refused to do it, because
I enjoyed the movie so much.
I thought to nit pick--
and maybe it goes
beyond nit picking--
but I just didn't want
to be part of criticizing
the movie in any way.
But I did refer them to the
fact that I did talk about them.
You can go on YouTube and
get my interviews with them.
So anyway, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Sure thing.
JAMES HANSEN: OK.
Well, again, thank you so much.
Clearly, I like to talk
about this guy a lot.
And I'll probably be doing
it for a while to come yet.
So if you haven't
seen the movie,
I hope you will go see it.
It's just a slice of his life.
And it doesn't-- it is based
on some nuggets that are
in my book, especially in
relation to the personal story.
But it doesn't have that child
is the father to the man aspect
that I think you really need to
have to understand who he is.
And I also-- the cover
of the book, it's
nice to see the cover.
It's Ryan Gosling.
But I would prefer if
you had the cover that
had Neil on the front.
There's another edition.
So you can go get that one, too.
Thank you very much.
SPEAKER: Thanks so much.